all right Vicki the tres amigas taken
over Bravo con so much fun
we just left and wait and greet and the
regrets that have the tres amigas shirts
on and they're yelling tres amigas and
other girls had the three white glasses
on we went to Florida just very fun the
fans really enjoy the tres amigas I hear
on a panel today you said you will not
accept being a friend again you want
that orange back well first of all when
they told me I was gonna have a reduced
role I said I'm never a friend I've
started this franchise I'm never gonna
be a friend they said we will never use
those words and they've been using those
words I will never come back part time I
mean they're all in are all out I'm not
a part-time girl
I mean I'm running a big insurance
company and I'm having my best year ever
with that what gives me more peace you
know I love Bravo and I love my journey
here but I'm not ever gonna do this to
me it's I don't deserve that I hear it
got contentious at the Reunion a little
bit wait what did you get a fight with
somebody how to bring up a can of
whoop-ass on who who did you have to
bring out the can of whup-ass really I
talked to her last night she was showing
off that ring on her finger and saying
that she liked to move to New York and
join the cast of Real Housewives of New
York okay what about her daughter
I mean I don't understand it I mean I
have two children and my kids know Steve
asleep asked for their permission in
your hand and my right I just don't
understand it
she's known three months marriage is a
huge huge undertaking and a commitment
and she's been married two times before
and why would you I don't understand why
they're rushing she pregnant I don't
understand let me take your time slow
down Steve took his time but he finally
put a ring on it and we're gonna get to
see that on the show very soon
how's wedding planning going well we're
we're clapping we don't have any date
yet we're I'm gonna first part of next
year we don't know if it's just gonna be
us going away or if we're gonna just
have a small family party or if our
friends I don't know I I just I'm all
over the place you know I don't know if
the viewers really may go into that
personal part of our life when he asked
me to marry oh that was in my pajamas I
hom had a bottle of wine
I'm like why are we doing around Tuesday
night you know and I have no idea but
he's very romantic and very private and
so for him that was anyone do it was it
wasn't for this show it was for us and
he loved and respected me was so about
us and that's my day lesser forever you
know if you're getting engaged for the
show if you're getting married for the
show fingers crossed get to see more of
you next year do you think Briana will
ever be on the show again or is she
really done with it
well she just lost 73 pounds she looks
incredible she's super happy
and then I say never but she doesn't
like the way that I was portrayed
retreated she's my girl and neither one
all of us or none of us I mean we're a
good family were dynamic families we
have six kids between Steve and I and
seven grandchildren so I you know I
think I'm gonna just wait to see and
then I've got to assess it you know I'm
a businesswoman it's all my business
time if it's gonna bring dishonesty and
angriness and drama
I want happy and uplifting only inspire
women I'm coming out with a podcast on
Westwood one about financial fitness and
I just started a community on Facebook
so I'm super happy about where I'm going
all right last question Andy told me the
reunion there's a meltdown to end all
meltdowns and I hear it might be your
meltdown do you feel like it was a
meltdown to end all meltdowns well I
didn't know they were filming actually I
I they escorted me off the couch a
little early and I was told that so you
see I'm not a [ __ ] friend let's just
put it that way
[Music]